alors c'est la première bonne nouvelle
de depuis le 10 février
ce gamin de six ans a passé 17 jours à
l'hôpital
de nombreuses interventions
chirurgicales et enfin il semble
commencer à reprendre une vie à peu près
normale il va à l'école uniquement le
matin parce qu'il est encore faible il
est donc retourné à l'école retrouver
ses copains
il a toujours des difficultés il a un
corset il a une difficulté pour parler
des difficultés pour manger enfin il est
pas
il a pas retrouvé la vie d'avant mais il
y a un formidable pas en avant et c'est
une vraie lueur d'espoir alors TF1
consacré donc un sujet sur Devrim pour
donner des nouvelles de son état de
santé et on entend l'enfant prononcer
quelques mots à côté de son oncle
regardez il a repris l'école seulement
hier 39 jours après l'accident causé par
Pierre Palmade le petit d'evrine 6 ans
ne prononce que ces quelques mots
une grosse cicatrice sur le crâne
un corset et un traumatisme profond son
oncle s'occupe de lui depuis l'accident
la mamie du petit donc la maman de yxel
l'homme toujours hospitalisé elle est
rentrée de Turquie pour être avec les
siens évidemment elle réclame justice
regardez la mère de youksel elle a
quitté temporairement la Turquie pour
être auprès des siens partagés entre une
profonde tristesse et sa colère envers
Pierre Palmade
j'aimerais que le coupable est comme de
la peine qu'il mérite c'est évidemment
ce que nous voulons comment
pourrions-nous attendre autre chose et
BFM a été encore plus loin et ils ont
interviewé plus longuement des rimes il
explique comment il se sent aujourd'hui
et évoque son retour à l'école
évidemment c'est vrai que ça fait
énormément parler ça et regardez
comment tu te sens aujourd'hui bien
c'est quoi ça ce que tu as là
avec le corset
[Musique]
qu'il gêne beaucoup et la journée se
demander s'il avait des souvenirs de
l'accident
et ça te gêne qu'est-ce que
ça fait maintenant plusieurs semaines
que tu es rentré à la maison est-ce que
tu te rappelles ce qu'il était arrivé
dans la voiture tu te rappelles pas ce
qui était arrivé dans dans la voiture
n'importe quoi qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce qu'il fait le mec là il est
conscient de ce qu'il fait là il est
parti voir le psy pour lui dire tu te
rappelles ce qui s'est passé dans la
voiture mais les adultes disent qu'ils
se rappellent pas ce qui s'est passé
plein de gens c'est quoi la prochaine
étape en fait tu vas à la casse et tu
essayes d'interviewer le mec qui a porté
la voiture sera dépanneuse tu essayes
d'interviewer quoi c'est je sais pas je
trouve ça les enfants laissez-les dans
leur monde d'enfant laissez-le lui tout
seul faire son truc se soigner guérir
moi je journaliste tu vois c'est pour
moi c'est pas ça j'en ai c'est pas aller
voir un gamin et tu te rappelles ce qui
s'est passé dans la voiture et la
voiture a fait des tonneaux ou tu as
entendu les bruits tu as vu des bouts de
verre tu as vu du sable c'est quoi ça va
mieux mais tu me dis dans les dans les
dans les journaux et dans les médias tu
m'as dit qu'il est sorti de l'hôpital il
va
non je suis pas heureux du mec qui va le
voir qui s'assoit au pied de son nid
pour lui dire ça fait énormément parler
moi j'aime pas du tout je suis désolé
couvert des deux parois là moi ça me
choque voilà donc tu as rien à dire
l'autorisation
les parents disent les parents sont dans
un combat pour que Pierre Palmade soit
jugé plus dur que ça donc
tu reçois un petit qui sort de l'hôpital
ça me dérange pas c'est ça en fait que
je voulais dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui ben
on fait que de parler de ça ça passionne
les gens on a envie de savoir comment va
ce petit garçon et effectivement si on
avait plus la voir nous et ben on
l'aurait on l'aurait reçu
on a besoin de voir on a besoin de
mettre des images dessus
là les gars je vous dis la vérité c'est
toujours la forme dessus c'est déjà
loué les mecs ils ont eu la torisation
des parents je dis pas ça pour toi mais
les autres j'ai vu qu'il y avait des
gars ils ont eu l'autorisation des
parents tout le monde l'aurait fait une
dernière fois
on a vu un gamin qu'elle avait plutôt
bien la tête de l'enfant ça se protège
les parents ont accepté tes pas c'est
parents qu'est-ce qui t'arrive là je dis
pas que tu sais parent je te dis que on
me présente une image et je me dis que
je suis révolté par cette image si les
parents veulent faire des interviews de
leur enfant c'est leur problème une fois
de plus mais je dis que le journaliste
qui vient au pied alors tant mieux
le journaliste a fait son boulot merci
Michel
je pense qu'en voyant ces images on a
envie peut-être de condamner plus
sévèrement encore celui qui est
responsable de cet accident c'est
l'information on est des journalistes on
est là pour informer et ça c'est une
attention je suis d'accord ce gamin
depuis le depuis l'accident on en entend
parler on l'imagine qu'est-ce qui est
choquant à partir du moment où les
parents sont d'accord qu'est-ce ce qui
est choquant de le manteau de voir
ce pauvre gosse enfin il se battent pour
que justice soit faite
je me demande même si c'est pas dans
l'intérêt même de l'avocat c'est les
parents en disant ça va ça va et
informer c'est le son et l'image merci
critiquent tout le monde aurait voulu
décrocher bien sûr moi je trouve
évidemment un élément de l'enquête au
début de la justice elle se fait aussi
en temps réel elle se fait aussi dans
les médias et le fait de voir cet enfant
la vidéo elle est bouleversante qui a
l'air d'aller mieux et tant mieux pour
lui mais tu auras probablement des
séquelles à vie bon on se rend compte de
la gravité de l'accident parce que les
victimes là on va en parler pendant
quelques mois mais après on en parlera
plus les séquelles c'est à vie pour eux
donc c'est un élément de l'enquête et
ils ont fait leur boulot ils ont raison
de leur faire faire les deux qui sont
sauvés de la voiture et les deux qui
étaient dans la maison
des victimes était venu la première fois
sur ce plateau il avait dit que les
victimes voulaient jamais apparaître
qu'on sache jamais qui elles étaient et
là il y a David il y a eu un changement
de stratégie